talk about the boden's spending plans
his immigration policy other issues
former senior adviser to president trump
stephen miller joins us
good evening good evening to you thank
you
i wanted to ask you star start with the
infrastructure plan which
we're calling the spending plan because
it's there's a lot more in there as we
know as
these plans are being laid out but even
on the infrastructure as you're
looking at if they get passed billions
and billions of dollars going to states
and
cities for projects there's another
element to this that you dealt with in
the processing
of getting projects through
yes i'd like to demystify this issue for
the american people tonight if i could
so as you know there's one
debate that's raging in washington right
now which is
why is only a quarter of the bill on
infrastructure as we would
conventionally define it and why is only
about five to ten percent
on roads and bridges that's an important
debate and it should be had
but let's talk about the money that
actually goes to infrastructure
what we learned in the trump
administration is only six percent of
non-military infrastructure in this
country
is federally owned so what does that
mean
state and locals run infrastructure in
this country
so when the federal government writes a
big check what state and local
governments do
is they take money that was already
committed to those projects
and they substitute federal dollars for
it so you don't actually end up with
net new infrastructure so if you spend
200 300 billion dollars
you don't end up with 300 billion
dollars in new infrastructure
there's a second problem too which is
the issue of shovel ready
it's a term we've heard a lot but what
it really means is
are you creating projects that are going
to have an immediate
benefit to a community not in 5 years or
10 years and 15 years
but right away and what we learned is
that the
single biggest impediment to shovel
ready
is federal state and local regulation
especially
the federal component of that regulation
if you accept one
federal dollar just one for your project
you know what comes with that 99 federal
rules and requirements that you have to
comply with as a result of that
that's why it takes five to seven years
to get a permit approved
so you can't have shuttle ready unless
you get rid of the
extreme fragmentation in the approval
process
and you have a single department the
department of transportation
make a single decision probably in three
to six months yes or no
and then require state and locals to be
just as
speedy to accept the federal dollar
so you're saying it's impossible if this
bill passes and becomes law for that
money to be spent on a state and local
level
without major changes in the way the
system works currently
to use a phrase from elizabeth warren
absent structural reform to how america
does infrastructure
to make it more the way canada does or
more the way australia does
is going to be wasted money it's not
going to go into the ground
and a huge portion of that money is
going to go to legal compliance
and consultants and not into actual
building and that's what we've seen for
decades in this country that's the
problem that has to get solved
all right uh you've been out and about
on number shows uh commenting on the
surge at the border
uh jen saki was asked about some of
those comments uh take a listen
we don't take our advice or counsel from
former president trump on immigration
policy which was
not only inhumane but ineffective
over the last four years we're going to
chart our own path forward and that
includes treating children with humanity
and respect and obviously you look at
the land border encounters as we just
talked about
in march 171 thousand but you also had
during the trump administration 103 000
back in 2019 as you look at these
numbers coming across
your thoughts reaction to the white
house and uh what's happening there
well let me take the last part first so
in 2019
after three years of court battles we
finally succeeded
at putting into place the tools that we
need
to immediately repatriate return or
remove
illegal immigrants to their own country
or to a third party country those tools
were fully in place by early 2020
and the border crisis was solved and
ended in a
permanent and enduring way if those
tools were in place then on top of that
we added on
for the pandemic title 42 which meant
that unaccompanied minors
could be swiftly repatriated to their
home countries and the unaccompanied
minor crisis
which has plagued us since 2013 was
ended
so between return to mexico and our safe
third agreements and title 42 for minors
we had a permanent complete enduring
unbeatable fix of the border crisis you
just had to leave it in place
undoing those tools created the
nightmare we're seeing today
now to the other point i find it deeply
insulting
to describe what we did is inhumane
we ended the process of human smuggling
and trafficking that destroys lives
that lead us to sexual assault that
leads to physical assault
and that finances the cartels creating
the cycle of violence and poverty
if the cartels had a vote they would
vote for
unanimously the border policies in place
under
biden it is making them rich beyond
their wildest dreams it is
inhumane to push men women and children
into the arms of traffickers and it's
also inhumane to have a policy that
means more drugs get across our border
because our border agents are dealing
with the humanitarian crisis
those drugs are getting going to end up
in u.s schools and u.s communities
poisoning american children
stephen miller we appreciate your time
on a couple of policy issues that you
worked on
thank you